If you think about RNNs in general,
they are a very general, trainable model
that maps variable-length
sequences to fixed-length vectors.
In fact, thanks to the sequence
generation and Bing search that we've
just discussed, they can also be made to
map fixed-length vectors to sequences.
Start from a vector, map it to the state
of your RNN, then produce a prediction.
Then sample from it,
or use Bing search, and
feed them back into the RNN
to get the next one.
Now you have those two building blocks,
and you can stitch them together.
It gives you a new model that maps
sequences of arbitrary lengths to other
sequences of arbitrary length.
And it's fully trainable.
What can you do with?
Many things.
Imagine that your input is
a sequence of English words and
you output a sequence of French words.
You've just built a machine
translation system.
All you need is some parallel text.
Imagine that your input is sounds and
your output words.
You've just built an end-to-end
speech recognition system.
Real systems based on variations on this
design exist and are very competitive.
In practice,
they do require a lot of data and
a lot of compute to work very well.
We've also talked about conv nets,
which basically map images
into vectors that represent
the content of that image.
So picture what would happen if you took
a conv net and connected it to an RNN.
You have an image going in, and
a sequence of things coming out.
A sequence of words maybe.
Maybe the caption for that image.
To do that,
you need training images and captions.
There are a few data sets out
there that you can use for that.
Most notably the coco data set.
It does images and
crowdsourced captions for them.
You can train a model that uses
a cov net to analyze the image and
generate captions from them.
And it works.
You can get great captions,
generated completely automatically, and
it sometimes fails in very,
very funny ways.